an asteroid hurtling towards Earth on
course to smash into the surface with
the force of a nuclear bomb it's a scary
prospect thankfully asteroid impacts of
this magnitude a rare but they do happen
and worryingly they can come without
warning in February of 2013 that's
exactly what happened near a small town
called Chell event in Russia nine months
on and scientists are starting to piece
together the details of this
once-in-a-lifetime event the answers
have come from an unlikely place YouTube
the Chelyabinsk asteroid was filmed from
hundreds of angles by hundreds of
cameras mobile phones security cameras
or dash cams small dashboard mounted
video cameras designed to tackle car
crime hiding inside these videos is a
wealth of information and that's helped
scientists build the most complete
picture of an asteroid impact to date so
what can you learn from a YouTube video
well researchers recreated the amateur
video shots but at night this allowed
them to use the Stars to pinpoint the
asteroids trajectory when the asteroid
hit the Earth's atmosphere it was
traveling at around 19 kilometres a
second at such massive speeds the drag
caused it to heat up eventually
exploding into a fireball and by
measuring the brightness of this
fireball the researchers estimated its
energy the explosion created a pressure
wave which hurtled towards earth
shattering thousands of windows and by
tracking the movement of shards of glass
as the window smashed scientists could
calculate the force of the pressure wave
all of this helped scientists work out
the Chelyabinsk asteroid was similar in
size to a six story building and the
fireball explosion was about seven times
larger than the nuclear bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima such huge explosions
are so rare that up until now scientists
have had to rely on models designed to
simulate nuclear bombs to understand
fireballs but the data gathered about
Chelyabinsk has allowed them to build
much more accurate models these suggests
that even large fireballs such as the
one over Chelyabinsk may cause less
damage than we'd expect unlike a bomb
which releases all of its energy from a
single point the fireballs energy is
spread out as it moves across the sky it
could be a century before the next
asteroid of this magnitude comes along
but when it does make sure to grab your
camera phone because scientists are
going to want to see it